italy's political future rests on this
man shoulders prime minister-designate
enrico letta has been taxed with putting
together a new government at a press
conference in Rome let her vow to put
Italy back on the path of political
reform and economic growth I'll
sensitive Italy can't wait any longer
that's why I've taken on this
responsibility even though it's a heavy
weight on my shoulders what Italy needs
right now is action Sharma has he gotten
a motive official letter has promised to
set a new course for Italy oh did you
get yellow City he wants to get the
European Union to soften its pro
austerity stands but he also supports a
strong Europe letta's measured stance on
the issues has made him friends and
enemies Queen DC basic is a fairly
balanced person with common sense I hope
he can form a government baby I'm ok da
Scott Acosta we do go there no indeed
Letta has sold himself he simply sold
himself I am NOT happy in fact i'm here
to show my disappointment money to study
room Letta is deputy leader of Italy's
centre-left party he has been in
politics for 46 years has twice held
ministerial posts and spent two years in
the EU Parliament de la responsabilidad
he is also the cousin of a key ally of
former prime minister silvio berlusconi
an important connection with Italy's
center-right Berlusconi has already
announced that his party is willing to
work with Letta it is a critical first
step to building a coalition government